[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لا تتردد
لا تتراجع لا تخف اسرع لتحقيق اهدافه
فلن تنطبلك الفرص
نيلسون مانديلا
في يوم من الايام وانا عمري 10 سنوات
[موسيقى]
وفجاه بتطلع الا في مره اسمها ام محمد
بتعيط
صغيره وحاولت اسمع شو بحكي اللي هي بتحكي
انها مروحه من المستشفى
[موسيقى]
الا هي بتحكي انه الدكتور حكى في عندي
كتله غير طبيعيه في صدري
والدموع تنزل من عيونها فجاه صرت احكي اوف
و شو يعني كتله غير طبيعيه
وشو بدها تؤثر في الجسم وما كنت بعرف انه
هذه الكتله هي الكتله السرطانيه
طيب شو يعني الكتله سرطانيه وفي خضم
الحديث الا هي بتحكي انه الدكتور حكي لها
لو جئت قبل سته اشهر او اكثر كان علاجك هو
بس الدواء ايش دواء وهسه شو هذا الدواء شو
هذا المرض
وليش الدكتور حكى لها هيك ليش كان قبل
بينفع دواء
وهسه ما بينفع
بعد فتره
وصل خبر
انه ام محمد
ماتت
انا بلشت اعرف شو يعني خزعه شو يعني كتله
غير طبيعيه شو يعني كتله سرطانيه طيب كيف
انا لما اكبر بدي ابعد عن هذا المرض كيف
بدي احمي امي واختي وعمتي وخالتي وكل اللي
بعرفهم من هذا المرض كيف ما بدي اخليهم
يعيطوا زي ما هاشوفك امي محمد
بس روحت على الدار قرات اكثر عن الموضوع
وعن المرض واللي صدقني اكثر هو احصائيات
في فلسطين والعالم اجبه فحسب تقرير منظمه
الصحه العالميه عام 2021 ان سرطان الثدي
هو اكثر انواع السرطانات شيوعا من بين
اكثر من اثنين فاصله اثنين مليون حاله في
عام 2020
تصاب قرابه امراه واحده من بين كل 12
امراه بسرطان الثدي في حياته
حينها استرجاع الذكريات لما كنت بدار
وكانت ام محمد بتعيط بس هالمره ما في
اسئله ببالي هالمره انا اوعى انا اكبر صرت
بعرف شو هو سرطان الثدي وهلا في اللحظه
هاي بدي ادور على علاج له بس انت يا اسراء
مش طبيبك اوكي اوكي اذا انا ما بدي اعالجه
بدي اخفف من اللي بقدر عليه
وفعلا وظلت الفكره براسي لحتى اجي علينا
برنامج لطلاب المدارس
على التفكير الناقد لايجاد حلول للمشاكل
المجتمعيه وحياتيا اول فكره انا تعبانه هي
الفحص المبكر لسرطان الثدي
وحكيت لاهلي هيك هيك والحمد لله ربنا
رزقني في اهل بيت عمي من البدايه الى
النهايه ومن قالوا مني او من الفكره
بالعكس سنه نزور دكاتره ومهندسين لحتى
نتعرف على طبيعه
وكيف ممكن يشتغل على المشروع وفعلا بلشت
اول شيء ابحث عن سرطان الثدي عن طريق جوجل
واليوتيوب اسره اتعرف حلفترق التشخيص من
خلال التصوير الاشعاعي والماموراف ودعم
المعلوماتيه بزيارتي لدكاتره جراحه مختصين
ومهتمين بهذا الموضوع
وبعدها صار كل شيء مركب بطريقه ماء براسه
وهسه صار بدي اطبق المشروع واسكنه فبلشك
اروح حلاوه مهندس واثنين وثلاثه والبعض
منهم كان بيعت منها طريقه خياليه او شبه
مستحيله وكان يسمعني كلمات
ولكن انا ما كنت اسمع هذه الكلمات بالعكس
كنت اروح واجيء واستشير واحد ثاني
اوه فعلا فكره من هان وفكره من هان
وجمعتهم مع بعض لا طلع مشروع
انت نفسك
ترسيون سوفت باير سوفت
[موسيقى]
و هو عباره عن اداه طبيه تمكن النساء من
فحص انفسه النباتيا من دون مساعده اي طبيب
واللي بيشتغل على مبدا فرق الضغط واللي
جربت بطريقتين الطريقه الاولى حلقه بني
محاكي لتدي الحقيقي حصلت عليه من اطباء
واللي كان يحتوي على كتل المحاكي الكتب
السرطانيه واللي كان يعطيني هذه نتائج
ايجابيه دقيقه بالطريقه الثانيه جربت على
قريبات من الدرجه الاولى واللي كان يعطيني
هذه نتائج سلبيه دقيقه
الحمد لله صرت بحكي اخيرا ضبطت ومن عقب
الى عقبه ومن تحدي لتحدي ومن تصفيات لا
تصفيات من بين اكثر من 7000 مشروع طلب في
المرحله الاولى
وصرت 40 مشروع طلب في المرحله النهائيه
في مسابقه وطنيه عن فئات الاختراعات
والابتكارات وهذا الفوز في الحمد لله مكني
اني اكون قبل شهر في وكاله ناسا للفضاء في
امريكا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي مكثف ده من باع بتاع فلسطينيه
واليوم من مكاني هذا بطنه انه يكون مشروعي
على 100 تجاريه فلسطين
خرجت من مخيم اللاجئين مخيم الفوار محدود
الامكانيات
للثنائي كاس العالميه
[تصفيق]
حتى التحديات انا كان هدفي واحد انه ما
يصير
زي قصه امي
خلينا نحكي شوي ونرجع لا قصه ام محمد لما
حلاتها الدكتور
[موسيقى]
شو اهميه البحث المبكر تظهر اعطاني الثدي
في حياته حسب منظمه الصحه العالميه بان
الفحص المبكر يزيد من نسبه الشفاء الى
اكثر من خمس سنوات
[موسيقى]
الى 30% وبيزيد من ثقه المراه
وشعورها بالامن والامان وهذا كان هدف
مشروعي
ابحثي نفسك بنفسك وهي فعلا
هذه الصوره كيف من بيت ستي اجتني فكره
طلعتني على وكاله ناسا وصراحه انا طموحي
ما راح قفلها بالعكس هاي نقطه الانطلاق في
حياتي راح تكون والان مشروعي في صدر
الحصول على براءه اختراع فلسطينيه
اليوم
بتمنى منكم
فلياس هو السبب الوحيد الذي يحول بيننا
وبين ما نريد
فكل الذين لم يصلوا كان بينهم وبين القمه
خطوه واحده
اغسل ياس ابصارهم عن ابصارها شوفوا اقراوا
قصص العظماء والناجحين الذين سطروا مثالا
في عدم الياس توما تكرار الفشل شايفين
النور اللي انا واقفه تحته هذا النور هو
بيقول ان شهد العالم اديسون بعد فشل متكبر
وبتمنى ما نسال مرحله بنقول يا ريت بعد
قوات الاوان
ان نعمل بحكمه الطبيب
كرمان عندما قال
لن نجد علاجا سحريا للسرطان يجب علينا
ان نعمله على وسائل للوقايه منه
واخيرا من مخيم محدود الامكانيات الى تحدد
في مجال الاختراعات والابتكارات الى
الوكاله ناسا في الفضاء والصناعات اذا
ارتدت بردات للارهاب والقطابات وان شاء
الله
تعالج الاورام
[تصفيق]
الفضاء لكم مني اطيب التحيات